2018 is shaping up to be a banner year
for sci-fi enthusiasts from a new entry
to the Star Wars franchise two
big-budget book to screen adaptations to
some very novel property ideas here's a
look at what the next year holds in
store for the cinematic genre the beyond
this feature-length debut from hostile
Lowell who previously worked as a visual
effects artist on films like The Dark
Knight and Hellboy 2 will be a loose
adaptation of his 2013 short film
project Chronos the beyond is set in the
near future when robotically augmented
astronauts embark on an interstellar
journey through a recently discovered
wormhole judging by the trailer or in
for a wild ride on this premieres on
digital streaming services On January
9th
Maze Runner the death cure the third
adaptation of James Dashner
dystopian Maze Runner novels the death
cure has been a long time coming the
film was originally slated for a 2017
release but a severe onset injury to
lead actor Dylan O'Brien temporarily
halted production on the pic and delayed
its release till next year
it stops when we find a cure there is no
cure it's it's been completed and the
death cure will follow the Gladers
continued battle with wicked in one
spectacular final showdown that hits
theaters January 26th annihilation based
on the acclaimed 2014 novel of the same
name by Jeff Vandermeer and directed by
ex machina Salix garland annihilation
follows a biologist as she goes
searching for answers about her
husband's disappearance by joining an
expedition into an environmental
disaster zone or the trailer that's
already packed with stunningly eerie
imagery there are sure to be a lot of
surprises when this movie lands in
theaters on February 23rd a wrinkle in
time for fans of Madeleine L'Engle --zz
classic 1962 science fiction fantasy
novel ava duvernay z' live-action take
on a wrinkle in time can't come soon
enough the novel has been adapted for
film once before in a 2003 Disney
distributed TV movie which was poorly
received by most viewers including
L'Engle herself who said I expected it
to be bad and it is but with an all-star
cast and the selma director at the helm
the new tank is already shaping up to be
an out-of-this-world experience when it
appears on March 9th Pacific Rim
uprising
Guillermo del Toro's Pacific Rim may not
have been a box-office smash but it was
well-received by critics and audiences
alike and has finally gotten its
long-overdue follow up by way of
uprising the sequel is held by Steven
tonight and while plot details are scant
so far we do know that John boyega will
feature as Jake Pentecost the son of
Idris Elba's characters stacker from the
first film it'll take place several
years after the events the first
installment so brace for impact
giant mech fans when this monster hits
theaters on March 23rd ready player one
Steven Spielberg is giving
science-fiction fans something to
salivate over with his adaptation of
Ernest Cline's buzzy book ready player
one in 2045 there's nowhere left to go
the story follows its young hero through
a virtual reality maze of pop-culture
references as he fights to find an
Easter egg that will earn him a fortune
in the midst of a global energy crisis
and from the looks of the early footage
the movie promises to be a mind-blowing
experience when it treks to the silver
screen on March 30th rampage monster
movies may have fallen out of vogue in
recent years but Dwayne the rock Johnson
may change all of that with the
big-screen adaptation of rampage the
film is based on the classic 1980s
arcade game of the same name which
features three gigantic monsters
rampaging through cities around North
America the producers of the movie have
confirmed that the main monsters from
the franchise will be back for the film
which means will soon be watching the
rock face off against the giant
crocodile a mega gorilla and an enormous
wolf oh you didn't know about the
30-foot wolf while this sounds like a
goofy action blockbuster on the surface
director Brad Payton also promises that
rampage will be a lot more emotional a
lot scarier and a lot more real than
you'd expect we'll have to wait and see
whether the rock can work his box-office
magic again when rampage drops on April
20th I think we'll be all right
solo a Star Wars story the upcoming Star
Wars film about Han Solo has hit some
bumps along the way but if it's anything
like its predecessors this will be one
out-of-this-world experience for
audiences the standalone movie will
follow a young Han Solo played by Alden
Ehrenreich who takes over for Harrison
Ford and will showcase the characters
exploits before the events of
new hope they'll be joined by Donald
Glover as a young Lando Calrissian and
Yona sua Tommo as Chewbacca taking over
for Peter Mayhew in addition to these
established Star Wars characters 40
Harrelson Emilia Clarke Fayette II
Newton Phoebe Waller bridge and more
will all appear in supporting roles
while shooting was underway in early
2017 production was halted after
Lucasfilm fired co-directors Phil Lord
and Christopher Miller due to ongoing
creative conflicts with both Lucasfilm
executive Kathleen Kennedy and
screenwriter Lawrence Kasdan however
Lucasfilm quickly hired Ron Howard to
complete principal photography and
reshoots judging by his willingness to
sprinkle the fan base with clues already
having Howard at the helm will make this
one outstanding intergalactic adventure
when solo hits theaters on May 25th
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom while many
other reboots have floundered in recent
years Jurassic world took the well world
by storm and earned over 1.6 billion
dollars in the global box office while
reintroducing scary dinosaurs to the
mainstream once again round 2 of the
revived franchise is Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom which promises a return
to its roots with a much darker tone in
the first installment plot details and
fallen Kingdom are still slim but we do
know that stars Chris Pratt Bryce Dallas
Howard and BD Wong will reprise their
roles from the first installment while
Jeff Goldblum will return as the
philosophical dr. Ian Malcolm which is
his first return to the franchise since
1997 the lost world
Malcolm's importance to the sequel is
hinted at strongly in the film's tagline
life finds a way
hints from those involved at the movie
indicate that the plot may involve
multiple competing labs hatching their
own dinosaurs off the island the ethical
issues and how they're using them and
how they'll coexist with humans in the
rest of the world the movie will return
to Isla Nublar for at least part of the
film and keep a watch out for the
original Jurassic Park t-rex which will
also be making a comeback with a promise
that the sequel will be more suspenseful
and scary than previous installments in
the franchise and with horror film
director Jay a Bayona at the helm
it sounds like Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom will be a must watch when it
finally arrives on June 22nd Elita
battle angel following in the footsteps
of old boy and ghost in the shell' Alita
battle angel will bring us delay
science-fiction movie based on a manga
the movie is directed by Robert
Rodriguez and will feature Rosa Salazar
in the title role with a supporting cast
including Christoph Waltz Maher Sheela
Ali ed skrein Michelle Rodriguez Qian
Johnson and Jennifer Connelly among
others plot details have been scarce so
far but we do know that it will focus
primarily on the plot of the mangas
first four volumes particularly on the
futuristic sport of motor ball the film
has been a passion project of producer
James Cameron who became a fan of Yuuki
toca Shiro's original manga nearly two
decades ago he's been trying to get the
film made ever since although he's had
to delay production along the way in
order to finish his avatar films and
develop the additional technology needed
to do a leta correctly with Cameron and
Rodriguez leading the way aleena battle
angel is sure to please science fiction
fans action fans and manga fans alike
when it reaches the silver screen on
July 20th the predator while the
predator is extra the fourth film in the
core predator series chronologically
it's set in the present day between the
events of 1990s predator 2 and 2010's
predators the film will star Boyd
Holbrook as an ex-marine who discovers
that predators exist and recruits a team
to help hunt them down rounding out his
team include cast mates Olivia Munn
trivanti Rhodes keegan-michael key
sterling K Brown Alfie Allen and child
actor Jacob Tremblay who will play
Quinn's son the other supporting cast
members include Yvonne Strahovski and
Edward James Olmos as well as Jake Busey
will make an appearance as the son of
Peter Keyes from predator 2 who was
played by his real-life father Gary
Busey Shane black who played Hawkins in
the original predator has returned to
the franchise this time as the director
black wants to keep the spirit of the
original film alive with this sequel and
has made it clear that it won't be rated
pg-13
cast member sterling K Brown has also
dropped hints at the predator will have
many wicked funny moments much like the
original film if black can truly capture
the nostalgia of predator while keeping
the story fresh predator should be a
true blockbuster when it hits theaters
in August 3rd captive state based on the
fuzzy screenplay written by Rupert Wyatt
and Erica beanie captive state will
start John Goodman fear farmiga Ashton
Sanders Jonathan majors
Kevin Dunn and Machine Gun Kelly among
others the official description tells us
the movie
be set in Chicago neighborhood nearly a
decade after an occupation by an
extraterrestrial force and explores the
lives on both sides of the conflict the
collaborators and the dissidents you can
catch the film in theaters on August
17th darkest minds this upcoming
science-fiction superpowers movie is
based on the novel of the same name by
Alexandra Bracken the darkest minds is
being directed by Jennifer yuh Nelson
and her live-action directorial debut
the story centers on the years after
disease sweeps America killing nearly
all of the children as surviving kids
develop uncontrollable superhuman
abilities and are confined to internment
camps around the nation Hunger Games
star Amandla Stenberg will star as ruby
a girl decides to break out of the camp
and join a group of rebel teens and a
plot to bring down the government which
wants to keep them under lock and key
joining Stenberg are Harris Dickinson
Mandy Moore Patrick Gibson's Skyland
Brooks and Gwendoline Christie who will
play a brutal bounty hunter tasked with
tracking down the missing teens since
it's based upon a young adult novel the
live-action adaptation of the darkest
minds will likely be a pg-13 film that
will appeal the teens and adults alike
and will premiere on September 14th
mortal engines maced on the novel of the
same name by Philip Reeve mortal engines
will take us into a futuristic steampunk
world following the ravages of a
60-minute war in this future cities are
now mobile moving around the world
propelled by gigantic engines and wheels
along the way the cities cannibalize
smaller towns to replenish their own
resources longtime Peter Jackson's
storyboard artist and collaborator
Kristian rivers will make his feature
film directorial debut with mortal
engines while Jackson will produce the
screenplay was also written by Jackson
along with his frequent writing partners
Philippa boyens and Fran Walsh stowing
Robert Sheehan para helm are Ronin
Raftery
and Hugo Weaving mortal engines should
be a visual extravaganza with a
compelling story that will blow viewers
away when it floats into theaters on
December 14th code 8 not only is code 8
the first feature film from actors
Robbie and Stephen Amell it was also
nearly completely crowd funded via an
IndieGoGo campaign in 2016 the emelles
who are cousins released a 10-minute
long short film which they were seeking
to expand to a feature length
in it the emelles take a different view
on the mutant superpower trope in their
future approximately 4% of people have
various supernatural powers but they're
mostly shunned by the rest of the
population forced to live on the fringes
of society specials struggle with
poverty and have to take low-paying jobs
as day laborers to make ends meet when
two of these specials get into a
confrontation with militarized police
things go violently wrong stowing robbie
and stephen amell Sung Kang aaron abrams
in chad donna la principal photography
on KO date began in June 2017 and is
tentatively slated for a December 2018
release thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]